so let's try to find the solutions to
this equation right over here we have
the quantity 2x minus 3 squared and that
is equal to 4x minus 6 I encourage you
to pause the video and give it a shot
and I'll give you a little bit of a hint
you could do this in the traditional way
of expanding this out but there might
and then turning it into a kind of a
classic quadratic form but there might
be a faster or a simpler way to do this
if you really pay attention to the
structure of both sides of this equation
well let's look at this we have 2x minus
3 squared on the left hand side on the
right hand side we have 4x minus 6
well 4x minus 6 that's just 2 times 2x
minus 3 let me be clear there so this is
the same thing as 2x minus 3 squared is
equal to 4x minus 6 if i factor out a 2
that's 2 times 2x minus 3 and so this is
really interesting we have something
squared is equal to 2 times that
something so if we can solve for the
something let me be very clear here so
the stuff in blue squared is equal to 2
times the stuff in blue so if we can
solve for what the stuff in blue could
be equal to then we could solve for X
and I'll show you that right now so
let's say let's just replace 2x minus 3
we'll do a little bit of a substitution
let's replace that with let's replace it
with P so let's say that P P is equal to
2x minus 3 well then this equation
simplifies quite nicely the left hand
side becomes P squared P squared is
equal to 2 times 2 times P because once
again 2x minus 3 is P 2 times P and now
we just have to solve for P and I'll
switch to just one color now so we can
write this as if we subtract 2 P from
both sides we can get P squared minus 2
P is equal to 0 and we can factor out a
P so we get P times P minus 2 is equal
to 0
and we've seen this show multiple times
if I have the product of two things in
the equal to zero at least one of them
needs to be equal to zero so either P is
equal to 0 or P minus 2 is equal to 0
well if P minus 2 is equal to 0 that
means P is equal to 2 so either P equals
0 or P equals 2 well we're not quite
done yet because we wanted to solve for
X not for P but luckily we know that 2x
minus 3 is equal to P so now we could
say either either 2x minus 3 is going to
be equal to this p value is going to be
equal to 0 or 2x minus 3 is going to be
equal to this p value is going to be
equal to 2 and so this is pretty
straightforward to solve add 3 to both
sides you get 2x is equal to 3 divide
both sides by 2 and we get X is equal to
3 halves or over here if we add 3 to
both sides we get 2x is equal to 5
divide both sides by 2 and you get X is
equal to 5 halves so these are the
possible solutions and this is pretty
neat this one right over here you can
almost do this in your head it was nice
and simple well if you were to expand
this out and then subtract this it would
have been a much more complex set of
operations that you would have done you
still would have hopefully gotten to the
right answer however just taking a lot
more steps but here we could appreciate
some patterns that we saw in our
equations and namely we have this thing
being squared and then we have 2 times
that same thing 2 times 2x minus 3